on en parle donc en premier avec vous
elena volochine on sait que la liberté
d'expression était bafouée et ces
dernières années en russie là très
clairement en train de passer à la
vitesse supérieure oui effectivement ça
a commencé il ya quelques jours avec la
fermeture donc de echo de moscou vous en
parlais à l'instant dans le sujet aussi
la rédaction de la chaîne de télévision
du web télévision indépendant doj
puisqu'il ya quelques années déjà deux
jeunes a été réprimée et était passé des
tas de télévision au web télévision et
maintenant ce média extrêmement influent
et de référence de l'opposition russe a
été obligé de fermer toute la rédaction
a par ailleurs quitté la russie et puis
pas plus tard qu'aujourd'hui donc encore
escalade avec la fermeture des sites web
de la bbc de mes 12 ha de voice of
america de radio liberty qui déjà été
déclarées agents de l'étranger papa par
l'état russe et puis la bbc a été placé
sur sur une liste j'ai vu ça pour la
première fois aujourd'hui dans deux
médias qui appelle à l'extrémisme aux
désordres de masse donc ça c'est des
mots qui jusqu'à présent étaient
employées pour pourchasser les opposants
et à la société civile mais c'est la
première fois que je vois ces termes
employés à l'égard des médias donc là
vraiment on monte d'un cran dans la
répression de la liberté d'expression et
les quelques les russes qui cherchait
une voie alternative et une opinion
alternatives ont deux ont de moins en
moins d espace pour le faire en sachant
que déjà de nombreux russes étaient très
fatigués de ce conflit et nous informer
plus vraiment il ya encore quelques
espaces wauquiez d'au moins en moins
d'espacé est ce que ça veut dire que
d'une manière ou d'une autre on peut
encore entendre trouver des voix
dissonante dans l'espace dans la station
là c'est vraiment un problème parce que
au delà au delà des désirs des
utilisateurs qui devrait aller sur
internet pour choper éventuellement lire
des médias en langue en langue anglaise
par exemple parce que encore une fois
les médias d'opposition ou indépendants
en langue russe sont en train de fermer
mais qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir dire et
raconter en étant à l'intérieur de la
russie ça c'est la grande question est
comment les journalistes vont pouvoir
continuer à travailler parce que il y a
donc cette loi sur les faits que news
qui a été adoptée à l'unanimité
aujourd'hui au parlement voit qu'on est
vraiment temps de guerre parce que même
si le parlement russe est inféodée à
vladimir poutine mais en général vous
avez quand même quelques voix
dissonantes pour voter contre les lois
là c'est l'unanimité pour cette loi donc
sur les faits que news qui compte qui
touche aux actions de l'armée c'est à
dire que toute publication qui est
concernée est considérée par l'état
russe comme étant non songeur quant aux
actions militaires de la russie en ce
moment est passible de 15 ans de prison
or on sait que en ce moment l'état russe
a une notion toute relative de la vérité
est que sa vérité n'est pas celle qui
est en réalité la vérité puisque l'état
russe interdit même d'employer le mot
guerre pour parler de ce qui se passe en
ukraine en parlant d' opérations
militaires spéciales et donc
concrètement si on aussi si on parle de
guerre en réussit à votre avis à rentrer
dans le cadre de cette loi on n'est pas
si potentiellement oui de prison oui
complètement ça a été explicitement
interdite sur parle de guerre en russie
le simple fait normal a le droit de dire
qu'il y à une guerre en ukraine c'est à
dire que explicitement hier ou
avant-hier l'état au début de
l'intervention l'état russe a dit vous
n'avez pas le droit d'employer le mot
guerre vous n'avez pas le droit de citer
d'autres sources que les sources
officielles russes dans vos publications
ça ça concerne les médias russes qui
travaillent en russie et donc les fakes
news effectivement c'est vous employer
le mot guerre c'est une fake news c'est
pas vrai il n'ya pas de guerre vous
dites qu'il y à des pertes que l'armée
russe subi des pertes ce n'est pas vrai
vous dites que la russie est en train de
mener une agression en ukraine ce n'est
pas vrai vous vous démentez le fait
qu'on est dans une opération de
dénazification vous êtes dans le faux et
d'ailleurs je tiens à souligner que la
loi sur les faits qui news elle a été
adoptée en 2019 pour la première fois
dit sur les faits qui nous la
formulation est un petit peu différente
mais c'était pour pour punir entre
autres les publications qui touchait au
co vide c'est à dire que l'état russe
était dans une logique un petit peu
triomphaliste on avait en vain le coc
vide et c est à ce moment là c'était
interdit de parler des morts et c est
donc là on voit que cette loi elle qui
était déjà avec des termes assez vague
et aurait pu déjà être appliquée
présentement mais il y a encore cette
loi qui se durcit qui qui qui est de
nouveau adopté avec des mesures cette
fois de prison des peines de prison est
donc vraiment on sent au niveau des
journalistes que ça va être complètement
impossible de travailler dans ces elena
on n'a pas beaucoup de temps mais jour
je voudrais quand même vous poser une
question sur les conséquences de tout ça
on sait que des milliers d'arrestations
en russie depuis le début de cette
guerre à quel point est ce que les gens
ont peur de parler de prendre position
publiquement
alors ça c'est un phénomène qui n'est
pas nouveau on le fait que les sondages
d'opinion sont tous relatifs aussi en
russie que les gens souvent saab de
façon instinctive qu'ils ne peuvent pas
dire ce qu'il pense tout parce qu'il
risque la répression c'est un phénomène
qui existe depuis depuis des années
maintenant je regardais le dernier
sondage de popularité de la dîmière
poutine aujourd'hui l'institut vtsiom à
donnent 70% de cote de confiance à
vladimir poutine là dedans c'est très
difficile de démêler qu'est ce qui
relève de cette espèce de sursaut
patriotique des russes sur fond de
propagande très durs par temps de guerre
et qu'est ce qui relève effectivement de
la peur de donner son opinion c'est très
difficile a sondé je pense qu'il ya une
grande partie là de la population russe
on ne sait pas si une majorité ou une
minorité silencieuse qu'ils
n'approuveraient pas ses actions mais en
tout cas il ya aussi ce sursaut ce
d'adhésion pour le moment en tout cas
derrière vladimir poutine dû à cette
propagande merci beaucoup et léna
volochine correspondante en temps normal
donc de france 24 à moscou merci d'avoir
été avec nous